1.3 billion people rely on livestock for
food nutrition and livelihoods animal
Source foods provide crucial nutrients
that are not easily obtained from other
sources meat leather wool and milk make
up 40% of agricultural value in high
income countries and 20% in lowincome
countries but according to FAO livestock
contributes 12% of global greenhouse
gases including 30% of anthropogenic
methane worldwide varying across
production systems and regions about 88%
of these emissions come from anic
digestion of ruminants released through
belching the remainder comes from manure
greenhouse gases including methane
contribute to global warming and climate
change while today low to Middle inome
countries and high inome countries
produce around the same amount of
livestock methane emissions it is
expected that by 2050 66% of global
livestock emissions will be from Low
Middle inome countries as populations
and incomes grow this means that we must
work to ensure that the development of
the sector occurs along a low emissions
pathway countries need to reduce methane
from livestock digestion and manure to
hit their climate targets and transition
to more sustainable and efficient
livestock
production most currently available
methane reducing Technologies Target
feed Technologies include methane
Inhibitors tanniferous forages lipid
diet supplementation concentrate feeds
and genetic selection of animals that
produce less methane from their
food it's the microbes in ruminant
stomachs which produce the methane and
there are ways to alter this methane
Inhibitors that Target these microbes
can reduce methane emissions by an
average 30% per
cow one of the most promising is B
scientifically known as three nitrooxy
propanol B has been developed by Swiss
Dutch company d SM fermanich and is now
approved for use in more than 50
countries for systems where livestock
mainly feed through grazing pasture and
rangelands the only effective approach
is to increase the productivity of the
animal through climate smart livestock
practices this includes improving feed
and forage Animal Health pasture and
rangeland
management we can produce emissions from
manure using simple interventions like
managing moisture and oxygen levels
microbes which don't need oxygen can
convert methane into biogas which has a
double benefit as it can also save use
of fossil
fuels what is needed to develop and
scale these
Technologies first we need more testing
in different livestock production
contexts to take many Technologies from
early stages to practical implementation
at scale secondly we need government
policies and incentives such as
subsidies to reduce the cost of
Technologies together with regulatory
standards thirdly Farmers need to know
about the Technologies and require
training on how to use them taking into
consideration social and cultural
norms and fourthly we need to remove
financial and Market constraints for
producers we need more private sector
investment and public sector
incentives consumers need the price of
animal products produced in a
sustainable way to be kept
low if we're going to successfully
reduce livestock emissions the
International Community needs to come
together we need to share good practices
and Innovation we need policy Solutions
that encourage the private sector to
invest and research to fill gaps in
knowledge on livestock and
climate investing in climate smart
livestock practices is the best way to
reduce methane emissions in low to
Middle inome countries whilst also
improving livestock health and
productivity by doing so we not only
help farmers adapt to climate change but
we also reduce livestock's carbon
footprint
[Music]